Nos interesa mucho más que eso.
Nos interesa el clima.
Esto es años, milenios,
y necesitamos ir a escalas aún menores.
A lo que no podemos resolver,
los procesos de las subescalas,
necesitamos aproximarnos de algún modo.
Es un reto enorme.
En la década de 1990, los modelos climatológicos
tomaban un trozo aún más pequeño,
de tan solo tres órdenes de magnitud,
En la década actual,
estamos trabajando con alrededor de
4 órdenes de magnitud.
Nos faltan 14
y estamos aumentando nuestra capacidad
de simularlos alrededor
de un orden de magnitud por década.
Un orden extra de magnitud en espacio
equivale a 10 000 veces más cálculos.
Y seguimos añadiendo más cosas,
más preguntas a estos diversos modelos.
¿Cómo se ve un modelo climático?
Este es un modelo climático antiguo,
una tarjeta perforada, una línea de código Fortran.
Ya no usamos tarjetas perforadas.
Pero aún empleamos Fortran.
Las ideas modernas como el lenguaje C
no han tenido un gran impacto
en la comunidad de modelado climático.
Pero ¿cómo seguimos haciéndolo?
¿Cómo vamos de la complejidad que vieron
a una línea de código?
Lo hacemos uno por uno.
Esta es una imagen de mar de hielo
tomada en un sobrevuelo en el Ártico
Podemos ver las distintas ecuaciones
que describen el crecimiento de hielo
o su derretimiento o cambio de forma.
Podemos ver los flujos.
Podemos ver el ritmo al que
la nieve se convierte en hielo, y podemos codificarlo.
Podemos encapsularlo en un código.
Estos modelos son de cerca
de un millón de líneas de código en este punto.
y crecen unas decenas de miles de líneas de código
cada año.
Pueden ver esta pieza,
pero también las demás piezas.
¿Qué pasa cuando hay nubes?
¿Qué pasa cuando las nubes se forman,
se disipan, se precipitan?
Es otra pieza.
¿Qué pasa cuando la radiación solar
que penetra la atmósfera
se absorbe y se refleja?
Podemos codificar cada uno de ellos también en piezas muy pequeñas.
Hay otras piezas:
Los vientos que cambian las corrientes oceánicas.
Podemos hablar del papel de la vegetación
en el transporte del agua del suelo
hacia la atmósfera.
Y cada uno de esos diversos elementos
pueden encapsularse y ponerse en un sistema.
Cada una de esas partes termina por sumarse al conjunto.
Y el resultado es similar a esto.
Una hermosa representación
de lo que sucede en el sistema climático,
en el que cada uno de esos
patrones emergentes que pueden ver,
los remolinos en el Océano del sur,
el ciclón tropical en el Golfo de México,
y otros dos más por surgir
en el Pacífico en cualquier momento,
esos ríos de agua atmosférica,
todos esos son propiedades emergentes
que provienen de las interacciones
de todos esos procesos a pequeña escala que mencioné.
No hay un código que diga
"Haga un giro en el océano del sur".
"Haga dos ciclones que giren uno en torno del otro".
Todas esas cosas son propiedades emergentes.
Todo esto está muy bien. Es grandioso.
Pero lo que queremos saber es
¿qué pasa con todas esas propiedades emergentes
cuando pateamos el sistema?
¿Qué pasa con esas propiedades cuando algo cambia?
Y hay muchas maneras distintas de patear el sistema.
Hay tambaleos en la órbita terrestre
a lo largo de cientos de millones de años
que alteran el clima.
Hay cambios en los ciclos solares,
cada 11 años aproximadamente, que cambian el clima
Grandes volcanes se apagan y cambian el clima.
Cambios en la quema de biomasa, humo,
partículas en aerosol y todas esas cosas
alteran el clima.
El hoyo en la capa de ozono alteró el clima.
La deforestación cambia el clima
al cambiar las propiedades de la superficie
y en cómo se evapora del agua
y en cómo se mueve en el sistema.
Las estelas de condensación alteran el clima
al crear nubes en donde no había
y, desde luego, los gases de efecto invernadero alteran el sistema.
Cada uno de esos factores
nos da una oportunidad
para evaluar si entendemos
algo de este sistema.
Podemos ver
qué tan preciso es el modelo.
Hablo de "precisión" intencionalmente:
Los modelos no están bien o mal: siempre están mal.
Siempre son aproximaciones.
La pregunta que hay que hacerse
es si un modelo da más información
que algún otro.
Si es así, es preciso.
Este es el impacto del agujero en la capa de ozono
en la presión a nivel de mar, baja presión, alta presión,
alrededor de los mares del sur, alrededor de la Antártica.
Este es el dato observado.
Este es el modelo del dato.
Hay una buena similitud
porque entendemos la física
que controla las temperaturas en la estratósfera
y lo que hacen los vientos
alrededor de los mares del sur.
Podemos ver otros ejemplos.
La erupción del volcán Pinatubo en 1991
dejó una enorme cantidad de aerosoles, pequeñas partículas,
en la estratósfera.
Eso cambió el balance de radiación en el planeta entero.
Había menos energía llegando que antes,
así que la Tierra se enfrió
y esas líneas rojas y esas líneas verdes
son la diferencia entre lo que se esperaba
y lo que en realidad pasó.
Los modelos son precisos,
no solo a escala global,
sino en patrones locales.
Podría poner una docena más de ejemplos:
la precisión asociada con los ciclos solares
que cambia el ozono en la estratósfera;
la precisión asociada con los cambios en la órbita
durante 6000 años.
Podemos estudiarlos y los modelos son precisos.
Los modelos son precisos de acuerdo a las capas de hielo
de hace 20 000 años.
Los modelos son precisos
cuando se buscan tendencias en el siglo XX
entre décadas.
Los modelos son exitosos para modelar
surgimientos de lagos en el Atlántico norte
hace 8 000 años.
Y podemos tener una buena aproximación a los datos.
Cada uno de estos diferentes objetivos,
cada uno de las diferentes evaluaciones,
nos lleva a agregar mayor alcance
a estos modelos,
y nos lleva a situaciones
más y más complejas en las que podemos
hacer preguntas más y más interesantes,
como, ¿cómo el polvo del Sahara,
que pueden ver es naranja,
interactúa con los ciclones tropicales en el atlántico?
¿Cómo el aerosol orgánico de la quema de biomasa,
que pueden ver en puntos rojos,
interactúa con los patrones de nubes y lluvias?
¿Cómo la contaminación, que pueden ver
en los remolinos blancos de contaminación por sulfatos en Europa,
afecta la temperatura en la superficie
y en la luz solar que llega a la superficie?
Podemos ver esto en todo el mundo.
Podemos ver la contaminación de China.
Podemos ver el impacto de las tormentas
sobre las partículas de sal de mar en la atmósfera.
Podemos ver la combinación
de todas esas distintas cosas
ocurriendo al mismo tiempo
y podemos hacernos preguntas aún más interesantes.
¿Cómo coexisten la contaminación atmosférica y el clima?
¿Podemos cambiar elementos
que afectan tanto la contaminación como el clima?
La respuesta es sí.
Así que esta la historia del siglo XX.
El primero es el modelo.
El clima es un poco diferente
de lo que en realidad pasó.
La segunda son las observaciones.
Y vamos por la década de los treinta.
Hay cambios, están pasando cosas,
pero es como una especie ruido.
Mientras nos acercamos a la década de los setenta
las cosas empiezan a cambiar.
Empiezan a verse más similares,
y para el siglo XXI
ya estamos viendo el patrón del calentamiento global,
tanto en las observaciones como en el modelo.
Sabemos qué ocurrió en el siglo XX.
Sabemos que se hizo más cálido.
Sabemos dónde se hizo más cálido.
Y si le preguntan a los modelos por qué ocurrió
y dicen, bueno, bien, sí,
básicamente por el dióxido de carbono
que pusimos en la atmósfera.
Tenemos un buen ajuste
hasta el día de hoy.
Pero hay una razón fundamental de por qué recurrimos a los modelos
y es por esta frase.
Porque si tuviéramos mediciones del futuro
obviamente confiaríamos más en ellas que en los modelos,
pero desgraciadamente,
las mediciones del futuro todavía no están disponibles.
Así que cuando llegamos al futuro, hay diferencias.
El futuro es desconocido, es incierto
y hay alternativas.
Estas son las alternativas que tenemos.
Podemos hacer algo para mitigar
las emisiones de dióxido de carbono en la atmósfera.
Esa es la primera.
Podemos trabajar
para realmente bajarlos
para que al fin de siglo,
no sea mucho más de lo que hay ahora.
O lo dejamos a su suerte
y seguimos
con nuestra actitud de "no pasa nada".
La diferencia entre esas alternativas
se puede ver en los modelos.
Hay una gran cita
de Sherwood Rowland,
que ganó el Premio Nobel de Química
por estudiar el agotamiento del ozono,
cuando estaba aceptando el premio Nobel
preguntó lo siguiente:
¿Cuál es el fin de desarrollar una ciencia
capaz de hacer predicciones, si al final
todos nos quedamos quietos
esperando a que se hagan realidad?
Los modelos son precisos,
pero lo que hagamos con la información de esos modelos
está en nuestras manos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)